a lazio foi uma união dos povos que quem
fala é o dado que tudo muito bem vindos
é mais um deles choraram que todo o
vídeo meu começo com o la olla já
tranqula se um impacto muito grande
estou acumulando não respondeu e vamos
lá vamos estar aqui fora eu soube na
opinião só terão mais desenvolta tá com
19 acertos muito com isso é portanto
vamos lá para que uma idéia é que a
gente veja o vídeo dos perguntam vocês
vão perguntar não poderia falar por uma
câmera sozinha é mais onde vamos
implementar a equipe só é [ __ ] se uma
proposta que estão aí e todo time que eu
sempre quis ter esconderam por uma
criatura tal como nina que não só
embalagem eu sabia que a sua moeda moeda
duros na areia antes nós temos é que
nosso setor vantagem só vão sentar kits
de uma meta que métodos face
lula que os mesmos vivem o drama do
pescoço
ai ai outra coisa de sua boca e só
tomará parte desses quatro aqui porque
aqui atrás de vocês que é uma coisa
muito especial no próximo biênio a
empresa que mais vamos agora tem 58 a 56
questões e este sol este é o nosso
retorno voluntário e agora tenho que
fazer apresentações ainda não está
ligado não sei se foi isso que o agora
supostamente está aqui tem que cuidar
aqui ok é este o botão liga com sol
aumentar ou baixar a sensibilidade e
vamos lá então baixar tudo já está no
mínimo e agora vamos ver funcional e
voltar aqui o meu relógio ou
experimentar esta sabe vamos implementar
moedas moedas
já preparei que algumas moedas que vamos
agora ver se funciona ou não funciona
21 vai lembrar agora roger na boa eu
faço agora vamos fazer e vamos andar
aqui pela casa própria ambientais e
vamos tentar ver se o pessoal aqui da
casa usando como moeda
ainda com fios de ouro com esse tipo de
coisas e vamos ver com qualquer coisa
funciona através de comprar um novo
tanto que vamos fazer eu vou fingir que
o mesmo time
[Música]
vamos lá então abaixo de um dígito em
tal pai tal
o setor de metais amamentar e cuidar das
pedras pela ahb que não pára de aumentar
[Risadas]
espero ver não causar qualquer coisa não
tal é o óculos acho que é o mesmo item e
apanhar as moedas
funciona assim só uma vida de outubro
com equipamentos estragados
o bbb é um caso de uma coisa que foi
lançado à água em elétrons elétrons
positivos e negativos cristo em
constante mutação com os mesmos que
geram eletricidade estática e lances
dados confirmam em contato com a cmtu
desligada
oi meu olho eu sabia que devia valer a
pena só agora são os ricos somos
poderosos graças é um um brinquedo
brinquedo qualidade brinquedo que não
estraga a primeira né mas não chega
ainda precisamos encontrar diamantes uma
lâmina de diamantino ou estão indício
domina do diamante por baixo desta casa
estamos gratos este brinquedo de carlos
rique caso
[Música]
reco e um filho e sua mãe com uma
paródia uma coisa assim ia brincar no
próprio equipamento tribos na hora de
poder ouvir umas perguntas tenham saído
piada mesmo e aí já sabem que o atlético
vai tentar bater os 100 m lápis porque
nem recebe dólar ea escola não é deus
[Música]